in the meantime i don't know i don't
have all the answers obviously but
one thing that i do is i make sure that
even if i hate it
i watch information from sources i don't
agree with
um and there are a bunch of sources that
i really don't agree with and i've found
even more insufferable but i've
continued to force myself
to watch these things to get you know
they'll watch certain people's coverage
of certain events to get the other facts
to get the other facts
what are these what would you say so
let's say that i am which i am
a person who wants to try and at least
get a broad cross-section
of what's going on what would you advise
that i read and listen to
well i mean the the most obvious place
starts like though if you're gonna watch
the mainstream news um watch fox news
and msnbc and you'll hear two sides
of the same narrative that will include
facts that the other one didn't include
so you will learn things from both sides
um
and that's essentially what you've got
to do on any subject any any given event
uh so i i find myself you know watching
like david pakman or novara media
and at the same time watching sean
hannity and tucker carlson
and i i mean like i don't really like
fox news i don't really like any of the
personalities other than tucker
carlson's i think he's actually
on the money a lot these days um but
basically you've got to find yourself a
sort of list of people on either side of
any
political debate who you find tolerable
that you can watch even if you disagree
with them
you've just got to figure it out you
know and you've just got to accept that
they see the world differently to you
but you still do need to have both of
those things this is something that um
hayek pointed out in the road serfdom
that the the dangers of totalitarianism
the reason that totalitarian societies
become like they are is not because of
propaganda
in in every society there's propaganda
it's just in a liberal society
there's a plurality of propaganda
pulling you in all different directions
so you're introduced to all different
kinds of things so you don't ever get
okay i've only heard one thing
so i really that's reality and that's it
you know because you see
something so messy that it's almost
impossible to work out what's going on
well no no no no no no no it makes it
impossible to work out what's going on
it means it's
much more difficult to find yourself in
a political cult
where you've only heard one side of the
story you've never heard the other side
okay so
you can still you know you can find out
what's going on from all this plurality
of sources
it's just you won't be radicalized to
one particular worldview or the other
um and it's it's not that it's not wrong
for people to have
their own political opinions they put
out obviously everyone's free to do so
um the danger with totalitarian
societies it creates radicals and
crazies who are zealots for the system
because they only ever hear one thing
and so the other people must be evil
and our social media feeds are doing
that for
us so it's really important that we
remember that we're not 100 right and we
are actually kind of self-radicalizing
and we've got to try and
decondition ourselves we need to
take everything that we read with an
increasing pinch of salt but the problem
is now as you've identified
the old bastions of truth
that we would be able to rely on a long
time ago they're no longer there
because they also have an agenda and
they also have pressures and
they also get stuff wrong and like so
yeah
again layer all of this on top of the
worst global pandemic in a hundred years
and everyone being locked in the house
and
heightened tensions and emotions and
stuff like that thirty people died in
the black lives matter protests in
america
thirty people died like those videos go
you know this one guy got beaten
unconscious then his teeth kicked in
just as he's laying on the floor someone
punched him straight in the face and i
watched i was like
you know and you know 30 police officers
in london were injured at the black
lives matter protest and then another 20
when the football ads went down you know
again i'm not going to say that it's
only one side that's done or anything
like that you know but
but if i were a partisan on either side
i absolutely would and the bbc and sky
news absolutely did make it sound
as if the black lives matter mostly
peaceful protest that injured 30 cops
you know like that you see the video of
the horse running down the street
yeah yeah because someone chucked a bike
and rocks at it and stuff like that